here at 4 30 a record 16 million
americans reportedly have
already cast their ballots for president
this year but
just because a ballot is returned early
doesn't mean
it'll be counted early or at all good
afternoon thanks for joining us here i'm
denise valdez
and i'm kirsten joyce with this story
more than 300 election related lawsuits
in at least 40 states have been filed so
far this year and many
challenged some aspect of mail and
balloting including witness requirements
and ballot deadlines
tony decouple got a rare behind the
scenes access
to an election office to show us what
might happen to our ballot once it
arrives
oh see we gotta get them out wow
results in the 2020 election are already
pouring in
yeah heavier than yesterday these are
absentee ballots in rockland county new
york democracy happening before our eyes
and kristen zabrausti stavisky and
patricia giblin are co-election
commissioners here
a democrat and a republican working
together
can i help you um sure
really all right rhonda you're in
joe you're in see that but nationally
republicans and democrats are fighting
this is going to be a fraud like you've
never seen not only to turn out their
voters
he is throwing up every roadblock to try
and suppress
the vote but to make sure that each vote
is legitimate
and counted and sometimes when there are
challenges
people will say you know without that
stamp we're not sure when it got here
what you're about to see is perhaps the
most consequential moment in the journey
of a typical mail-in ballot
so the first thing we would do is scan
it in
and then we're going to just view the
signature
oh wow when election workers try to
verify
that a vote is genuine but checking the
signature against what's on file
trisha and i would make a ruling yep
well the commissioners asked us to blur
voters names we got to see
exactly how much variation they're
willing to accept
we're looking at substantial
similarities right so we're not
handwriting experts we're not sitting
there saying oh that y is
slightly different that's not going to
count if your ballot is going to get
hung up though
this is most likely where it will happen
and in a close election
that could be decisive across the u.s
missing or mismatched signatures doomed
more than
and fifty thousand ballots in 2016. and
sure enough
this looks very different very different
yeah so that's an issue
this voter's signature sent the
commissioners in search of additional
documentation so now we're going to look
at her
absentee application
batman matches and we watched as they
looked through four signatures on file
so it almost appears like she has
a very serious signature as the voters
say a quick signature
it just seems like the pen strokes are
different i don't
i don't want to get involved it's your
call the decision
rejected at least for now we may talk to
her
and see she may sign an attestation that
she actually completed the ballot
in new york and at least 18 other states
voters are notified if their ballot has
been rejected
and given an opportunity to fix it in a
process known as ballot curing
but in most of the country there is no
such requirement
so the ballots can be tossed out and not
only for signature issues
this isn't sealed we saw two other
ballots set aside because the internal
envelopes
weren't sealed though those were
eventually accepted with no evidence of
tampering this right here
just to put a fine point on it this
demonstrates why it's so important for
people to take extreme care
that's right when they're filling out
their ballot that's right after the
initial checks the sealed ballots are
scanned in
move to a storage room it's really
secure
look at that all right there's three
locks
democratic lock a republican lock and
if we were ever impounded by the court
that lock would be for the sheriff
in new york they aren't actually counted
until three days after the polls close
so state officials can compare a list of
absentee voters against the names of
those who voted in person
so the point of the delay in counting is
to make sure
no one is double voting yes yes election
results are always unofficial
on election night that's true for every
state in america
where any vote can be contested or even
thrown out
and this year that fight is expected to
be fiercer than most
why at this busy time did you want to
show us this
i think it's all about transparency we
want to show the voters
first how hard we work that their ballot
is going to be secure
when it's here and then we're concerned
about their ballot and we will take
every precaution we can
we want to demystify it right people
don't know when they're
nervous about things because they don't
know so
even though we're extremely busy right
now this gives us the opportunity to say
to people look this is what happens to
your ballot
we take it seriously we want your vote
to be counted
and these are all the steps we take to
make sure it does
it's tony decouple reporting you can
find much more information about our
local election rules
by going to our website eight newsnow
dot com denis